tu es un remaniement qui casse pas la
baraque en veut dire un c'est un
remaniement avec beaucoup de changements
de chaises musicales c'est un jeu de
chaises musicales mais bon ce que je
retiens c'est qu'évidemment le leur qui
a été le nouveau monde temps vendu par
emmanuel macron on voit bien qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya besoin de compétences
c'est chez nous qu'on vient les chercher
moi j'ai envie de dire à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent ce matin qu'il vaut mieux
voter pour les républicains avec des
personnalités qui sont fidèles à leurs
convictions et à leur programme que de
choisir des gens qui retournent leur
veste en fonction du vent oui mais votez
pour nous n'allez pas voter pour ceux
qui partent ailleurs en reniant leur
conviction restons fidèles à nos
convictions
restons chez les républicains la pause
au programme pour la france
oui mais sauf que jean castex il a
déniché des répliques yahia yonne
il ya trois jours quand elle est
brouillée premier ministre ben oui
qu'est ce qui reste de l'année blick
abattant des vous avez pas me dire que
parce qu'il ya trois personnes dans mes
jean castex suis sûr vous connaissez
même pas avant qu'il soit nommé ou mais
sans évidemment arrêté voir personne ne
le connaissez jean castex qui est
d'ailleurs par ailleurs un haut
fonctionnaire
en fait si les dents dans vraiment dans
dans le profil que recherche
macron de droite parce qu'il faut un peu
déstabilisé les républicains c'est quand
même son adversaire principal les
républicains les temps sont quand même
dur pour les républicains
vous voyez une bonne partie de 2,2 des
gens qui sont les plus brillants chez
vous au logis quillan passe je fais ça
ou si vous saviez vous voyez pas le
vivier énorme que vous enfermez la
preuve y en a même pas la république en
marche est-ce qu emmanuel macron et mais
j'ai eu de trouver un son premier
ministre dans sa majorité de
parlementaires une force politique chez
les la république aux marches mais ce
n'est pas du tout les droits
slada rien y'a personne chez eux sauf
que souffle chez nous la force